pues ayer hubo varios momentos
destacados que escuchamos la
intervención de 17 figuras destacadas
dentro del partido de la vieja guardia
del partido demócrata como puede ser el
ex presidente jimmy carr y bill clinton
que precisamente fue quien tuvo ese
discurso más agresivo más incisivo y
crítico sobre la gestión que está
haciendo donald trump durante su
presidencia vimos también la
intervención de jóvenes figuras dentro
del partido como ya lo comentaba es de
la famosa congresista popular
congresista alexandria ocasio cortez
quien un día en un discurso bastante
breve de tan sólo 60 segundos pero sí
que es verdad que acaparó la mayor parte
de la atención la noche de ayer y mostró
su apoyo su voto al que fuera candidato
a la privada a la candidatura demócrata
bernie sanders que como explicaba se
retiró pero ayer por la noche también
podría también se daba la opción de
votar le vimos los 57 representantes de
territorios estatales y federales que
con unos breves vídeos hicieron su voz
y vimos también la denominación formal
de este candidato demócrata que la
recibió desde delaware con un breve
discurso y sin duda el momento más
emotivo llegó de la mano de su mujer
jill biden que precisamente no es
nuestro como decía ese es el lado más
humano del candidato y nos explicó cómo
superar el dolor algo que seguramente
conectó con muchos estadounidenses que
durante esta pandemia han perdido
familiares o amigos también que podemos
esperar para hoy cuáles eran los platos
fuertes de este miércoles en la noche
que oradores esperamos si os va será una
jornada muy interesante de santiago
vamos a escuchar el discurso de
aceptación como candidata a la
vicepresidenta de kamala harris a la que
hemos escuchado pronunciar un poquito en
estos dos primeros días hoy por fin
vamos a poder escucharla ella va a dar
un discurso desde el agua en un discurso
grabado desde delaware en el que se
espera que la hace toda su artillería
contra el presidente de donald trump
escucharemos también mujeres de la talla
de la ex precandidata hillary clinton
nancy pelosi y desde luego va a ser una
jornada muy interesante lamentable
muchísimas gracias por este completo
reporte desde nueva york